es wird ein irres wissenschaftliches
ereignis bald schon werden wir das erste
abbild eines schwarzen loches zu sehen
bekommt bisher war dies nicht möglich zu
viele schwierigkeiten gibt es ein echtes
bild zu machen aber forschungsteams
haben das größte radioteleskop der welt
zusammen gebaut und im april dieses foto
gemacht doch erst jetzt kann es
berechnet werden und da laufen die
großrechner auf hochtouren auf whatsapp
haben viele nach dem stand der dinge
gefragt hier ist der bei pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
der wahnsinn so ein schwarzes loch und
eigentlich nichts besonderes es scheint
unglaubliche mengen davon zu geben was
auch nicht verwundert denn eine
grundlegende eigenschaft eines schwarzen
loches hat quasi jeder gegenstand sogar
ein atom den schwarz schild radios 1916
kam der deutsche astronom carl schwarz
schild auf die idee das ist bei jeder
masse einen kugelförmigen horizont geben
müsse bei dem die gravitation so groß
ist dass nichts mehr aus dieser kugel
entweichen kann bei allem was wir sehen
können ist dieser radius so klein dass
die außengrenze dieses radius der
ereignishorizont so klein ist dass ich
eben die materie außerhalb dieses
horizonts befindet und damit sichtbar
ist bei der sonne beträgt dieser schwarz
schild radius beispielsweise drei
kilometer sie hat eine masse von zwei
quint millionen kilogramm
da ist er genauso groß würde also die
masse der sonne auf eine größe unter
diesem radius zusammenstürzen dann würde
ein mini schwarzes loch entstehen
das geht aber nicht da ihr eigengewicht
nicht groß genug ist um die kräfte die
gegen die gravitation wirken zu
überwinden war sternen die aber deutlich
schwerer als die sonne sind passiert das
wenn am ende die fusion zum erliegen
kommt und sie als supernova explodieren
und dann mehr als die dreifache
sonnenmasse übrig bleibt dann ist deren
gewicht so stark dass sie zu einem
schwarzen loch zusammenstürzen man kann
sich das so vorstellen dass die
gravitation so stark ist dass auf
unserer erde zum beispiel übertragen
berge in sich zusammenstürzen wir selber
wir menschen in die erde gezogen werden
und es immer und immer dichter wird und
dadurch die kräfte noch stärker werden
weil sich die masse auf eine noch
kleinere kugel verdichtet und am schluss
forschungsteams weltweit vermuten einen
unendlich kleinen punkt im zentrum eines
schwarzen loches aber letztendlich
wissen wir es nicht bisher konnten wir
schwarze löcher nur messen um sie herum
kreis die materie und wird heißt bevor
sie in das schwarze loch stürzt diese
heiße strahlung können wir messen und so
wissen wir wo schwarze löcher sind und
das absolut irre ist wahrscheinlich gibt
es auch im zentrum von galaxien und
wahrscheinlich sogar in allen galaxien
so ein schwarzes loch nur ist es
die sich absolut gigantisch und enthält
die masse von millionen sonnen oder
milliarden ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße
da haben wir ein solches schwarzes loch
gefunden um das zentrum unserer
milchstraße rasen nämlich sterne mit
einem affenzahn der schnellste stern mit
einem tempo von 18 millionen kilometern
pro stunde alle 15 jahre hat er die
runde um sagittarius a stern gemacht so
wurde das schwarze loch in der mitte
unserer galaxie nämlich benannt was
diesen daten wissen wir übrigens also
aus der entfernung und der
geschwindigkeit ziemlich genau wie groß
das schwarze loch ist vier millionen
sonnenmassen hat es und einen schwarz
schild radius von 12 millionen
kilometern wir hier in unserem
sonnensystem haben übrigens einen
sicheren abstand von 26.000 nicht jahren
zum zentrum
da sind wir einigermaßen sicher also das
ist wirklich extrem bei den fährt aber
ein foto von diesem schwarzen loch das
können wir wegen dieser große entfernung
einfach nicht machen
es hat die größe eines tennisballs auf
dem mond im vergleich und nicht nur das
es so klein ist es ist auch so viel im
weg dass es einfach nicht sichtbar ist
da sind nebel aus gas und aus staub die
einfach die sicht verwehren was also tun
eigentlich ist es einfach aber dann auch
wieder kompliziert elektromagnetische
wellen mit langen wellenlängen
durchdringen diese nebel aber und jetzt
kommt der haken die sind so langweilig
dass ein bild davon nur sehr unscharf
werden würde aber die forschungsteams
waren erfinderisch was wäre wenn wir zu
einem ein ganz viele radioteleskop
zusammenschalten würden und was wäre
wenn wir sie einige tage auf das
schwarze loch richten ersteres würde das
bild deutlich schärfer machen und durch
die dauer der messung also diese
mehreren tage würden wir viel mehr daten
bekommen
gesagt getan im april machte das event
horizon teleskop diese spektakuläre
aufnahme zahlreicher radioteleskope rund
um die erde wurden zusammen geschaltet
und richteten sich zeitlich zehn tage
lang auf sagt carius a stern aus und
jetzt soll schon bald das bild vorliegen
es wird der hammer zumindest dass wir es
sehen denn aufgrund der erdrotation der
langen aufnahme wird es wahrscheinlich
sowie eine langzeitbelichtung mit
entsprechenden schmieren und so weiter
ja wie vielleicht dieses bild aussehen
vielleicht können nur
wissenschaftlerinnen etwas damit
anfangen vielleicht wird es aber auch
spektakulär die letzten daten zur
berechnung sind aus der antarktis vom
dortigen südpol teleskop am 13
dezember 2017 zum high stake
observatorien rechenzentrum in den usa
ausgeflogen worden und werden jetzt
berechnet mitbeteiligt eine berechnung
ist das rechenzentrum am max planck
institut für radioastronomie in bonn es
wird sehr sehr spannend was wir sehen
werden
in diesem gebiet ist die raumzeit
nämlich unglaublich gegründet kann
könnte also sehr seltsam aussehen aber
und das ist unglaublich spannend
wir werden hinter das schwarze loch
sehen können denn es ist eine
gravitationslinse und wird uns unsere
galaxie also die teile unserer galaxie
hinter ihm zeigen wahnsinn ich bin
wahnsinnig gespannt meine frage an euch
soll ich dann einen live stream zum
thema machen also wie letztlich zum
start der falcon heavy schreibt es unten
in den kommentaren
wenn ihr diesen live streamen nicht
verpassen wollt und meine anderen videos
zu allen anderen themen dann meldet euch
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video eben
vorab garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt
in der redaktion von kriegs- und
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder andere vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
drauf kriegen und natürlich nicht das
abo mit der genau glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken mysteriöses schwarzes loch
wirft theorie über schwarze löcher um
sehr sehr spannend ansonsten bis dann
bleibt da